رمز الحرب الاوكرانيه الجديد ضخمه ساحه
للمعركه الاطول مده والاكثر كلفه في الحرب
الدائره حتى اللحظه وفي الايام الاخيره
ازداد الضغط بشكل كبير على القوات
الاوكرانيه التي تدافع عن باخمت في مواجهه
التقدم الروسي والتهديد بتطويقها اما
اليوم فقد اعلن قائد مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه
ان قواته استولت على الجزء الشرقي باكمله
من مدينه لكن في المقابل يبدو ان فاجنر
تعاني حيث كشف قائد فاجنر يافيني ان قوته
تعاني من نقص في الذخيره على الخطوط
الاماميه وهو ما اكده مقطع فيديو نشر
لقائد قوات اثناء حديثه مع احد المقاتلين
وهو يتحدث عن نقص الذخيره وعن المساعدات
التي تصل للقوات على الارض
وتعليقا على تطورات الميدانيه في باخمه
حضر الرئيس الاوكراني من انه اذا استولت
القوات الروسيه على باخمت فسيصبح الطريق
مفتوحا امام قوه موسكو للاستيلاء على مدن
عديده شرقي البلاد مضيفا ان الدفاع عن
ضخمه مساله استراتيجيه بالنسبه لاوكرانيا
وان قوته مصممه على الدفاع عن المدينه
ومنع سقوطها بايدي الجيش الروسي